[Music]
today's question comes from trina in
california
trina says my husband and i have four
children ranging in age from seven to
fifteen
we live in a three-bedroom two-bath home
so the kids share two bedrooms and a
small bathroom
my oldest daughter has anxiety disorder
and insomnia so she struggles with
having to share a room it's also hard on
her siblings to share a room with her
she's constantly looking at bigger homes
for sale in our town and when we tell
her we're not moving she begs us to let
her move in with her best friend or
grandparents so she can have a room of
her own
are we being selfish because we chose a
smaller house that we can afford my
therapist suggested we consider moving
into a bigger house with a 30-year
mortgage just to give her that space for
the next three years and then downsize
again when she is on her own
so to answer your question here are we
being selfish because we are living in a
home the size of which we can afford the
answer is no
good for you
um i think we have a culture christie
where people have
to buy caught gigantic cars they can't
afford gigantic homes they can't afford
so everyone's got a bathroom everyone's
got a room and everyone's got a yard
everyone's got a pony and whatever
um so no
you're not being selfish if you're
living a smaller house that you can
afford
if you try to if you the reality is you
live in a smaller home and you have a
lot of people people are sharing rooms
then you have to be hyper intentional
about connectivity about roles about how
who is not here's the rules of our house
but here's why you matter here
and kids feel a desperate need for
connection and they feel a desperate
need for purpose
and if you just plop a 12 year old in a
15 year old's room and say y'all figure
it out yeah dude we're not going to
figure that out so the easiest thing
here is to run is to punt this down the
road let's take on another couple
hundred thousand dollars in mortgage
debt so that we can what i'm telling you
this won't solve the problem right you
won't solve the problem you'll have a
15-year-old who disappears for three
years and then moves out you will not
have healed or supported or helped your
daughter you may have quieted the chaos
for a minute my guess is you won't um
when kids have anxiety when they've got
insomnia when they've got ocd when
they've got adhd
i always want parents and this is myself
included here
understand most of the time your kids
bodies aren't broken or disordered those
that anxiety that insomnia that is your
body saying i'm not safe there's
something going on here i'm not okay
it's not because there's somebody
sharing my room with me most of the time
it is something bigger than that so i
want to look at those challenges not as
things to run from but as let's get into
trying to figure out what your body's
trying to tell you here yeah and those
are hard and those are messy and i'll
tell you if your therapist is telling
you yeah you know what you should
do put your family at risk in a
situation financially that you can't
afford to placate a 15 year old you may
need to get a new therapist right that's
a that's a tough situation they put you
in what do you think
yeah i guess it just for me one of the
hardest parts about this it's not just
about the house or about the money i
totally agree with you obviously you you
need to live a house you can afford and
and figure out what's really going on
that's probably not the room i think one
of the hard things and i'm curious your
thoughts on this when it comes to
parenting and i still consider myself
pretty new at this because my oldest is
six so i have been in the parenting game
for six years i just have three kids
under age sex
the hard thing is when they have
different needs
um not just that they're wired different
they have different personalities but
they have different needs
um it feels unfair to have different
expectations of them like that i would
expect of carter that he behaves
differently than my middle son conley
gotcha not just because their age but
because of their capacity right and so
how do you handle that where as the mom
as the parent as the dad you're going
okay we've got four kids one has some
things that she struggles with
and so and so how do you accommodate
that and make that child feel safe
while also not making it
quote unquote unfair or whatever with
the other kids in the household where
it's like okay we don't want to walk on
eggshells around this child because we
don't want to ignore these children and
do you see what i'm saying i don't feel
great i don't feel like i'm asking
anybody
perfectly but there's other kids
involved in this equation and how do you
help everybody when their needs are
different and their struggles are
different so the demon of
mental health challenges or more
specifically the demon of everybody's
body reacts differently to things
some people respond to chaos by getting
really loud some kids respond to chaos
by
trying to disappear become as small as
possible
the challenge here is you can't see it
and what i mean by that is my son is 11
and he's humongous i will ask him to go
grab uh hey we go grab that thing for me
while i'm in the middle of cooking
something because he's tall and he can
go get that right i won't ask my
five-year-old little little girl she's
very short i'm not gonna ask her to do
that that's beyond her capacity
similarly i want all my kids to get in
the car and go to target with me right
now even though she's exhausted he's
been running a track meet and he played
a baseball game and so i i tend to
moralize and and make issues of
character things i can't see
and so every kid's got different needs
and it may be that for a 15 year old who
is brain is saying we're not okay right
now i can't even go to sleep at night
because i'm scared something's not right
that tells me there's chaos in that home
that tells me there's third rails in
that home and that tells me that hey you
know what i really love i love our whole
family getting together for dinner that
might be the only hour of the day that
my 15 year old has time
to herself and so for this season i'm
going to concede that but you're going
to go on a walk with one of us with mom
or dad and that means mom or dad we're
not going to be able to watch our
favorite show every night of the week so
or we have to put our phones down and
fill in the blank right
it's about re-examining the entire
picture but no i think you're exactly
right as a parent i want all my kids to
do what i say and in the way i say it
because i have this picture of going to
the hardware store today i just got to
know that man she's got to go to sleep
right now yeah and he has asked can i
just have some time by myself and i'm
not going to do that to him yeah and
those sometimes those are issues of
character we're all going to store and
so when we're going i need you to be
respectful
most of the time that is something
that's exceeding their capacity and as a
parent i got to change my picture of
what that's going to look like yeah i
think that's so powerful and and
something we have to practice on a
regular basis
you let go of this picture of how you
thought it was going to be and one of
the things i learned from david thomas
who has written multiple books and he
i've had him on the christy great show
he's so smart but he's he he talks about
be okay with letting go of that picture
for this season it doesn't mean forever
but maybe in this season we're going to
let this child off the hook and they're
not going to have family dinners and
they're going to eat in their room or
eat on their own because they just need
some peace and quiet to themselves in
this season but see as a parent you
think like we're never going to eat as a
family again it becomes these extremes
in this season you can let go of your
expectations and the way that david
thomas said it which i love how he
talked about this he said for a better
outcome you can force it and everyone's
miserable and anxious and not sleeping
or you can say okay what what is needed
maybe we divide up sometimes matt and i
will split up the kids even though i
want everybody together but we'll split
them up for a better outcome right
saturday you're gonna take two i'm gonna
take one or vice versa and i just love
that it's it's a hard
step to take to say i'm going to let go
of what i wanted things to be
but if it's for a better outcome then
it's amazing because it really is that
act of love of saying this is going to
lead to better results for everybody
so think think this this guides me
if i
get
to a conversation with my wife and i win
and she loses we both lose that's right
when i get into a
piss and match with my kids
and i win and they lose we all lost yep
and so the goal is how can i even have
to make hard decisions hold my kids
accountable get them to do things they
didn't want to do
it's because of this outcome yeah and
they've got to know where we're headed
here yeah and i've got to be flexible in
that season yeah that's good being
willing to let go of that that's good
that was good good question great
question but i'm glad we talked about it
i know a lot of people probably can
relate to being in something similar